y obviamente qué
conmocionado
e
sinceramente difícil
algo totalmente
y eso
porque sabemos que el oro
se viene deteriorando mucho tiempo
e
pero igual no deja de
de ser un dolor para los que amamos el
deporte
un fenómeno de esto alguien que
en su época fue
el único que hizo cosas extraordinarias
en ti por juego
y bueno se vaya tan joven
este era el uno particular tratar de
de recordar lo grande que fue ante una
cancha
porque bueno no soy quién para
para juzgar
su vida personal
milan lo que lo rodea
e
pero tampoco
de qué es
voy a caer en el facilismo de decir este
fue un ejemplo dentro y fuera de la
cancha porque más así dentro de una
cancha de insisto yo tuve hasta la
oportunidad d
de enfrentarlo cuando en independiente
yo cuando él jugaba en boca en argentina
y la verdad me falta
era mi rival pero me faltaba un hilo y
había cosas que hacía aquí
que vos te preguntabas como las puede
hacer porque no sé de la forma que movía
su piel parece que no tuviera la
articulación del tobillo no aparece que
eso fuera
que fue hecho por dios de una manera
especial para desarrollar ese talento
así que prefiero prefiero recordarlo de
esa manera
y bueno
con mucha pena repito porque
portugal me hubiera querido que es su
vida posterior a una cancha
este les permitiera disfrutar de tantas
maravillas que la vida le dio
de otra manera y con más salud y por
mucho más años